دكتور اذا ما ابرز الرسائل التي وصلتك من
لقاء الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني
رئيس الوزراء القطري وزير الخارجيه خاصه
فيما قال بانه هناك احراز تقدم بشان وضع
الاسس ل المضيه قدما في مساله
الرها نعم يعني اعتقد انه هذه هي المساله
الاساسيه التي يعني سمعتها خلال اللقاء
بالاضافه الى
مسالتين تتعلق بحل الدولتين ومستقبل حركه
حماس ولكن لا شك انه في الوضع الراهن
المساله المركزيه هي موضوع الاسرى
والرهائن والتقدم الذي تم احرازه بالامس
في المباحثات الرباعيه فيما يتعلق بهذه
الصفقه طبعا هنالك الان في نقاش في
اسرائيل حول هذه الشروط طبعا الشروط الان
هي غير رسميه ولكن تم تسريب يعني بعض هذه
الشروط المتعلقه بالاساس بمده وقف اطلاق
النار و وب تفاصيل صفقه التبادل معنى
الاصر الفلسطينيين مقابل الاصر والرهائن
الاسرائيليين في قطاع غزه وكن بلا شك يعني
كما
قال وزير الخارجيه القطري هناك في تقدم
ملموس وحتى في اسرائيل هنالك في حديث عن
تقدم ملموس مع ان هنالك الكثير من العقبات
في داخل اسرائيل حول انجاز هذه الصفقه وفي
اعتقادي ان العقبه الاساسيه هي عقبه
اسرائيليه وغير متعلقه بحركه حماس الان
العقبه المركزيه كما سمعت حاليا او كما
استشفيت من هذا الحديث ومن ما يجري في
داخل اسرائيل ان هنالك في نقاش الان حاد
في داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه حول تفاصيل
هذه الصفقه وامكانيه اخراجها الى حيز
التنفيذ امم طيب في ظل في ظل يعني هذا
الرفض الاسرائيلي السابق وخاصه لبنيامين
نتنياهو لاي صفقه يجري الحديث الان عن
ايجابيه كما كما تفضلت ما الذي يمكن ان
تقدمه حكومه نتنياهو في وضعها الحالي فيما
يتعلق ب وزير الخارجيه رئيس الوزراء يتحدث
عن ربما مرحله لوقف اطلاق النار ايضا وليس
فقط هدنه واطلاق الرهائن
نعم يعني يعني حتى الان هنالك كان في
تاكيد اسرائيلي على سبيل المثال في
الساعات الاخيره كان في تاكيد اسرائيلي ان
هناك في تقدم ايجابي في صفقه تبادل اسر
ورائ ان وطبعا هنالك في اعضاء في الحكومه
يؤيدون ذلك ومباشره تم اصدار بيان مكتب
نتنياهو ينفي ان اسرائيل وافقت على شروط
هذه الصفقه بمعنى الان هنالك وكانه في
حاله من الصراعات الداخليه صراعات بين
اطراف في داخل الحكومه بين تيار يؤيد
الصفقه وبين تيار يعرض الصفقه هنالك في
مسالتين مركزيت في اعتقادي هما المسالتين
في داخل الحكومه المساله الاولى هي متعلقه
بالمده التي تطاع الصفقه ل هدنه في قطاع
غزه يتم الحديث عن يتم الحديث عن شهرين
ومتعلقه النقطه الثانيه متعلقه بعدد الاصر
الفلسطينيين الذين سوف يتم اطلاق سراحهم
الموضوع الاول هو المعره الاساسيه
الاسرائيليه هذا هو تخوف نتنياهو تخوف
نتنياهو ان وقف اطلاق النار لمده شهرين
على سبيل المثال سوف يؤدي او يفتح الطريق
الى وقف نهائي للحرب نتنياهو لا يرد ذلك
التخوف الثاني عند نتنياهو ان قبوله بوقف
اطلاق النار لمده شهرين ق قد تؤدي الى
تفكيك حكومته الداخليه بخروج اطراف من من
اليمين منها الامر الثالث الذي يخف
نتنياهو ان وقف اطلاق النار قد يؤدي الى
حراق سياسي في المجتمع الاسرائيلي يطالب
باستغلال هذه الفتره من اجل الذهاب الى
انتخابات الداخليه في اسرائيل هذه
التخوفات معا تخيف نتنياهو ولذلك هنالك في
الكثير من العقبات والتردد في داخل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه فيما يتعلق بهذا
الشرط الاساسي من الصفقه المتعلق بمده
الهدنه التي ممكن ان تقبلها اسرائيل في
اطار هذه الصفقه اذا امام هذه التخوفات ما
المتوقع من حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو ومن
نتنياهو شخصيا فيما يتعلق بهذا الملف ملف
اطلاق الرهائن والمحتجزين في قطاع
غزه
انا اعتقد اذا الامر كان متعلق بمن شخصيا
هو سوف يرفض اي صفقه نتنياهو بالنسبه له
هو مستعد ان يضحي بالاسر والران
الاسرائيليين مقابل بقاه في السلطه
والاستمرار واطار هذه الحرب هذا اذا لما
متعلق في قرار نتنياهو الشخصي ولكن هنالك
في اطراف في داخل الحكومه تؤيد صفقه تبادل
اسرى حتى لو تم دفع ثمن باهد بالنسبه
لاسرائيل هنالك ايضا الضغط الشعبي
المتصاعد في داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي الذي
يدفع نحو وتبني صفقه تبادل اصرى ورهاء حتى
لو تم وقف اطلاق النار لشهرين او حتى الى
ثلاثه هنالك تيار حتى يدعو الى وقف اطلاق
النار نهائيا من اجل ايه
ايه من اجل الصفقه ولذلك ال يعني
الديناميكيه في داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه
هي معقده مركبه ولكن في اعتقادي انه
بالنهايه سوف يتم الميل نحو قبول الصفقه
ولكن قد تضع اسرائيل شروط قد لا تقبلها قد
لا تقبلها حماس ايه ايه في هذا الصدر ولكن
الان التوجه الاسرائيلي هو نحو قبول صفقه
تبادل اسر ورهاء ولكن يبقى العائق الاساسي
هو بن يمين نتنياهو شخصيا امام اتمام هذه
الصفقه الديناميكيات الشعبيه الاجتماعيه
خارج الحكومه والديناميكيات السياسيه داخل
الحكومه قد تدفع بالنهايه بنيامين نتنياهو
الى الى القبول بهذه الصفقه مع وضع بعض
التحفظات على بعض بنودها وخاصه فيما يتعلق
بوقف اطلاق النار